foreign
[Music]
I'm Dave Rubin and this is the Reuben
report we've got another Friday Round
Table Extravaganza for you and joining
me are actually two of my favorite
guests uh the first one is
editor-in-chief of the post-millennial
Libby Emmons and the host of the news
and why it matters on Blaze TV Sarah
Gonzalez ladies welcome back to the
Reuben report
thanks for having us
it is good to be with you guys we're
just going to jump uh right into it
because I want you guys to help me with
a philosophical and spiritual issue that
I've been dealing with with this Trump
and DeSantis thing I don't like getting
in the muck and the mire with everybody
all the fighting and everything else but
I do think it's important to call out
sort of BS and lies and nonsense when
they come at you and I'm trying to
figure out how much I should be
addressing all this stuff so that's the
way I want to frame this first segment
that we are going to do because Donald
Trump uh went on the milk boys podcast I
think this is yesterday talking about
desantis's failures during covid what do
you think that um your biggest
competition lies within your own party
yeah
like from the people running in the Park
yeah yeah but they're really fading fast
I mean it's fading very very quickly uh
you have a guy from Florida Ron DeSantis
who I got in with my endorsement he was
at three points he was nothing he was
not going to win he was going to lose
and I endorsed him and then when they
asked him a couple not only there then I
got him through the general election he
was running against somebody who at the
time was considered very good as a
politician and then when they asked him
a few years later are you going to run
against the president he said I have no
comment I said that's not supposed to
happen he was uh he was dead politically
I endorsed him
and saved him had I endorsed he was
losing by like 25 30 points very shortly
before the election when I endorsed him
he went like a rocket ship like
you love that song like rocket man he
went like a rocky I should call him
Rocket Man but now he's rocket man
that's crashing his polls are
terrible I'm leaving him in every state
and uh we just came in with they just
came out with new polls I'm leading them
everywhere why do you think he's well
like besides that because he's done a
pretty good job with Florida you agree
why do you think you're a better choice
than DeSantis well actually if you look
at the numbers he didn't do a great job
if you take a look at the numbers he's
very high on crime very high we're right
at the top uh almost at the top uh he I
think he gets good publicity although
now people are starting because I'm
putting out the covet numbers he didn't
do well on covet he he had more deaths
and almost every country in Florida I
hate to say it because Florida's my
state
but he had he did not have he did not do
well it's it's really it's very
interesting I don't want to knock
anybody but the thing he did well on his
public relations because the numbers
weren't what uh they pretended to be
all right so there's so much there
because it's like good Trump and bad
Trump all wrapped in one which I guess
is what we get at this point look in
terms of endorsing him the first time
and helping him get over the hump it's
100 True obviously everyone knows it the
Santa says acknowledge that it's it's
not an issue okay fine all of the
coveted stuff I mean Trump who pushed
through warp speed still was telling
people to get boosters kept fouchy and
Berks okay fine we can get past all that
but to say that Florida didn't do well
Florida now gets 1200 people a day new
people still coming here because of the
ramifications of covet over a million
people he kept the state open after you
know everyone did the lockdowns right at
the top it's just like I moved two
companies here like everyone knows it
everyone knows it I I just don't like
that level of lying Trump's own family
two of his children Ivanka and Junior
moved down here during covet his
grandchildren moved down here during
covid
um what do we do about this stuff or
Sarah I'll start with you because I I
you supported Trump last time around I
don't know where you're at fully on this
thing right now but like what do we do
about trying to deal with this stuff
honestly not allowing the political
machinations to destroy everything but
still being honest about what's going on
here yeah well first of all I would like
to say Dave thank you so much for uh
making me wade into this Trump DeSantis
situation I just wanted to up your hate
on Twitter a little bit you don't get
enough when you're talking about the
trans stuff you know right right right
that I've been trying to very delicately
uh Walk the Line on because I like you
know both of them but you know as you
point out we can't lie about each other
like we have it's very important to be
accurate and I think that the
juxtaposition of of this is very
interesting because he's criticizing
DeSantis essentially what I'm getting
from this is he's criticizing desantis's
policy during covid which was of course
as you pointed out the free estate that
there was in the country so
am I to understand that Trump is
criticizing desantis's decision to keep
Florida free if so running as a
conservative that's a really big problem
for me so it's just it's frustrating to
have Trump not have the ability to in
hindsight it would be so easy for him to
say hey they gave me the wrong people to
trust they were you know they they
wanted me out they lied to me they lied
to the American people you know fauci
was lying Burks was lying and during the
swamp type thing and I think that his
his base would appreciate that and I
think that there would be some people
who might be turned off by him now who
would also appreciate that instead he
takes this bizarre route of well I was
the president at the time but everyone
else made poor decisions me insisting
that everyone shut their states down and
take a vaccine in order to go to work I
was the one who made the right decisions
it's just a very bizarre bizarre
juxtaposition for me right he's also
lying about the numbers and Florida has
the second oldest population in the
United States but even if they had the
most deaths you have to balance security
and freedom like this is like America
101 stuff Libby what do you think
you know I am getting really frustrated
with this whole uh this whole chicken
fight or whatever you want to call it
between Trump and DeSantis in large part
because
um DeSantis won't announce so he's
making all of the moves as though he's
running for president but he's not
actually saying that he's running for
president you can't really get a
straight answer on that he's been to
Iowa twice he's been to New Hampshire
he's going all around he's doing a
foreign policy tour I think coming up
um and also what that does is that
leaves him open to attacks but he's not
really in a position to attack back and
the other thing too between this you
know the two of them who are clearly The
Front Runners and there's a lot of
animosity among supporters of either one
and I think that they're playing it
entirely wrong you know either of these
gentlemen should be able to Garner the
support of pretty much the entire GOP
except if they attack each other and go
nuts so it's it's really a shame I think
to see this also the numbers on
Florida's crime I think crime I think
Florida is like somewhere in the middle
not really
um up top I think the a lot of the other
states that are led by Democrats are
substantially higher like New York
California Illinois places like this so
yeah I mean I would say DeSantis should
really announce if he's going to
announce and if he's not going to
announce then he should throw his
support behind Trump and we should take
this thing in 2024. right and also on
the on the crime side I mean Miami which
is the biggest city in Florida was voted
safest city in the United States safest
big city in the United States education
is doing extremely well here obviously
but I am with you I mean you guys could
go back anyone watching this can go back
to my videos before this whole fight
started from three months ago saying
guys just sit down at Mar-A-Lago or
wherever and talk it out but Libby I do
agree with you that because of the the
non-announcing situation with which has
a little bit to do with uh you know part
the Florida legislature and yet there's
some things are going to have to change
there
um it does put everybody in a bit of an
awkward situation I just want to throw
to One Clip this might be a little
gratuitous but there's about 4 000 of
them of trump praising the
[Music]
David Governor surge went down
is uh Sarah is that the weird thing that
in a way Trump has to go against his
base on covet if he's going to attack
DeSantis because his base is against
vaxes he was four vaxes and warp speed
and all that and as you said I think if
he just was like boy I really did get
bamboozled by fauci and the rest of them
I think clearly the base is going to
love him either way but it might show
some other people hey he's showing a
little Contrition and that's not really
his thing but that's kind of good yeah
no I totally agree unfortunately his ego
won't allow him to do so and I mean look
at the end of the day Trump's main uh I
think demo the thing that is most
important to him is loyalty you you know
you heard him in the first clip talk
about well you know I I was the one who
got him over the edge I was the one who
helped him become governor and while
it's true it also I don't think means
that Ron DeSantis can never run for
another office in his life if it
competes with Donald Trump so it's just
very frustrating because he's making all
of these decisions he's making all of
these statements only considering
loyalty rather than what's best for the
party what's best for the country any of
that and that's why we hear him go back
and forth and contradict himself and not
make sense and just say abject lies
giving in to the mainstream media's you
know obvious hit pieces on Ron DeSantis
at the time that he held the State of
Florida free so it's just frustrating to
see Trump just his ego just can't he
cannot help himself it is bizarre to see
MSNBC and Trump on the same side but
let's I always try to give the devil his
due on this show Libby what would you
say putting aside the situa this running
not running situation which I I'm
complete agreement with you what would
you say is desantis's biggest downside
like obviously we can talk about Trump
downside but I want this to be as uh as
Fair as possible
you know I think that um to a certain
extent his downside is that he won't
acknowledge Trump voters and he won't
acknowledge Trump's influence on the
party you never hear him say Trump I
know that he speaks about Trump
privately but he doesn't speak about him
publicly and when he does he doesn't use
his name and it's almost as though he is
discounting that America First Maga base
that got Trump elected and that has been
so supportive of DeSantis and if we
continue to see the conservative media
put their thumb on the scale for
DeSantis that's really going to turn off
a lot of that base and those base voters
don't have to vote they didn't
necessarily vote for before they may not
come out again and if they feel like
their guy who at this point is Donald
Trump as we keep seeing he gets record
numbers at rallies and all that kind of
stuff and if those voters see that their
guy is being summarily dismissed by the
conservative Intelligentsia as it is
then they're not going to come out for
DeSantis and I think to Santa really you
know Embrace those voters and embrace
their values which he may but he doesn't
really express it and uh those people
deserve a voice and it's a shame that
they're only getting it from one part of
the GOP at this point it's interesting
you see it that way because I mean the
book was rather effusive over Trump like
DeSantis book I mean he credited him a
million times there's not a word bad in
there I guess it's tough when somebody
keeps calling you a rhino and a
globalist to be like yes he is the
greatest guy in town well he doesn't
necessarily have to say that he's the
greatest guy in town but he does have to
acknowledge those voters and he does
have to do something about that base so
you know I I don't know if there's a way
to divide those voters from the from the
man that they necessarily support
um but I do think that those voters need
to be embraced I think they need to be
listened to and they need to feel like
they're part of this so if Trump is
successful in you know keeping those
voters to himself and keeping their
support
um then I think DeSantis is going to be
in trouble and I think the entire GOP
will be in trouble I don't think we need
all of this infighting we saw it in the
lead up to the midterms and it did not
help anybody out right I'll throw in one
other thing on this just to be fair I
mean you know DeSantis did this six-week
abortion thing this week and I have a
feeling both of you probably disagree
with me on this but I was fine with the
15 here in Florida I didn't hear anyone
complaining about it and I don't think
it helps you in the general because the
the population of the United States is
more moderate on abortion perhaps than
the the situation here in Florida I just
want to throw up one other poll on this
this is from The Wall Street Journal uh
they had from this week they have Biden
versus Trump it's Biden at 48 Trump at
45 and then DeSantis versus Biden it's
actually DeSantis leading 48 Biden 45 uh
briefly guys and then we can move on do
you make much of of polls at this point
I I tend not to but I thought there was
something interesting there
yeah I mean I tend not to as well but I
mean as you as you mentioned it is very
interesting and I keep you know the
longer it goes on here's the thing with
with this poll in particular right now
it's April of 2023. we have so much time
left where Trump could stick his foot in
his mouth a million times and you know
what so could DeSantis at this point
um but it is fascinating to see how they
will you know continue on because as you
you mentioned abortion uh Ron DeSantis
is making a much different decision
right now on abortion that Donald Trump
just made when he came out and said uh
that he doesn't think that abortion uh
the or pro-life uh measures should be
federalized he doesn't think that the
issue of abortion should be federalized
there should be no federal law that that
indicates that women cannot have
abortion that's how that's going to play
to the base is going to be really
interesting so it'll be fascinating to
see where they stand on the policies as
we go further and I think that you know
the polls will continue to shift so I
don't put too much into the this poll
but I do find it interesting that
DeSantis is up there by the way I happen
to agree with Trump that it shouldn't be
federalized that was the whole point of
reversing Roe v Wade but that's a
separate issue all right let's jump on
to the next thing uh so this is really a
rather incredible we could it's nice
that we bang the right up a little bit
because we can always go back to the
left and they make it very easy for us
uh this is a hearing from this week
Biden's interior secretary her name is
Deb Holland and she started crying while
talking about climate change because
we're dealing with a bunch of very
serious professionals
changes the crisis of our lifetime
we have an obligation to Future
generations to make sure that we have a
planet for them to live on and that's
why I'm here and that's why I'm working
incredibly hard to make sure that we can
realize that transition that we can have
diff differing energy sources we can't
continue to be a one industry uh country
Libby this lady is going to save us all
it's so incredible I I don't believe any
of this anymore I really am I am so I
don't know if that's red pilled or black
filled at this point I don't believe any
of this and even if I believed any of it
the idea that that woman and Joe Biden
and AOC could fix any of it is so
bananas it's off the charts
yeah I agree with you I think they are
totally bananas and I do think that
they're off the charts bananas
um and the other thing too is that the
energy sources that they are pushing are
not even proven to be better than fossil
fuels either in their uh you know in the
way that they are used and the benefit
to Society at large or in the way that
they are produced so I think that there
is a real disconnect here between Deb
Holland's tears and the tears of the
laborers that are working in the mines
in Africa to supply the lithium and
Cobalt and whatever other heavy metals
are needed to create these batteries
people look at their super clean
electric cars and they feel really good
about themselves and they don't have any
consideration for how they were made or
the waste that is produced when those
batteries die and they have to be
chucked into a landfill somewhere in
Southeast Asia so that kids can climb
all through the dump and pull out the
heavy metals and get poisoned themselves
and all like this the same same thing is
true for the way that solar panels are
manufactured and the materials that are
needed to create those these are these
are difficult manufacturing processes
and they they're the way the places that
these these materials are um these
products are made with these materials
do not have Fair labor standards right
these things are made in China it's
really deadly for the people who do them
and I think that it's a shame that Deb
Halen's tears are all about the people
in the United States making sure that
they can get their electric batteries
and have nothing to do with the
manufacturing process you know and
everyone forgets that fossil fuels
lifted half the population of the world
out of poverty and now we want to Chuck
them back into it more people die every
year of cold than heat yeah you know
it's funny one of the first things that
we did when I moved here to the Sunshine
State we had a solar system at the house
here and I had a expert come and tell me
you know what is it offsetting and how
much money am I gonna have to put in the
upkeep upkeep and blah blah blah and
basically he's like this thing's doing
nothing it was purely put here you know
to like make it look cool or whatever
and we got rid of it because I was just
like oh it doesn't even look good and
and that's a damn shame because I am in
the Sunshine State and I'm not opposed
to doing it and using solar power if it
would be effective uh Sarah the crying
part and the overly emoting is this will
they always beat us because of this like
I'm pretty sure neither one of you are
going to start crying during any of the
topics today and if you do you can't
come back but is that why they always
win
I don't know I think I'm gonna try to
compose myself for this question Dave
um I I do think that that is a lot of it
is that they use emotion to convey their
message because I mean look at what the
young people of this country are like on
climate change right now we have a whole
generation of young people growing up
who are told that they are going to die
if we don't do something and I mean we
joke about it but it's very real to them
because it's all that they've heard from
Academia from their education system
they have been indoctrinated into
thinking that they truly are going to
die and they don't have the perspective
that we have right like I can look back
at this and go oh this before covid I
might have been able to argue that the
the whole idea of you know climate
change uh would be the greatest scam of
all time because you go back 60 years um
1967 they said that there would be a
Great Famine by 1975 and everyone was
gonna die then we had you know uh the
Ice Age and then we had acid rain and
then we had global warming and then we
had global cooling I mean if you look
they have a very long history of telling
people that the climate that the weather
was going to kill everyone and somehow
it's 2023 and we're still alive and
kicking it but these young people don't
understand that right like they have
been indoctrinated into thinking this
and it's very real to them it's caused
uh major anxieties for them major
depression for them and they have
developed a very radical view on this
because they have been manipulated by
people like the Secretary of interior
who sit there and put on these fake
tears and pretend like she's actually
serious about this none of these people
are serious about this it's why Barack
Obama bought a 12 million dollar mansion
in Martha's Vineyard on the coast it's
why Al Gore has a home that uses like 32
times more uh you know energy than the
average American they don't believe any
of this Greta thune book Greta thunberg
flies her her private jet to the U.N
climate Summit right like none of these
people actually believe the the BS that
they are spewing and trying to force
onto the American people it's just all
about control because I'll tell you what
whenever here in Texas when we had that
uh the The Ice you know all of the the
were iced in for a very long time
um what some people noticed who had
these you know smart thermostats this
Smart Energy Systems uh were that that
their temperature was being regulated by
the power companies they would try to
turn on the heat and the power company
would regulate that and if people don't
think that that's what's coming once the
government has more control over all of
this green energy that they're promoting
for the general population they've got a
whole nother thing coming you know the
other part psychologically right I just
want to throw that out there dead on
just one other thing quick before I let
you and let me you know the other is
like the psychological element of the
hysteria that it leads to like Bernie
all the time will be like four out of
five young people are having climate
anxiety but it's because you're giving
them climate anxiety and you seem to be
happy to do it go ahead Libby yeah no I
just I totally agree I thought Sarah
said that perfectly this is just like uh
the new rain dance you know it's like we
think that what we do our human sins
have some great impact on the weather
and it's absolutely exactly the same
thing as our ancient ancestors did uh we
really have not progressed at all right
can I add in one more thing Dave sure
the other thing that is just so
disingenuous about this when it comes to
America and American politicians arguing
about this is that they know if you look
at the numbers and you look at emissions
anything that we do yes we won't matter
when you're not addressing China and
you're not addressing India and you're
not addressing all of the emissions that
are coming from there which we obviously
can't control like that would be a
minuscule little blip in any sort of
numbers and it would make no significant
difference and they know this that's why
they're it's just it's so disingenuous
it frustrates me well it's also it's
also ironic because the left that wants
us to have no role in in the world
basically or a diminished role what
right do we have to tell other countries
that are going through their own
industrial revolutions that they can't
do exactly what we did but uh check this
out so this is a representative Harriet
Hageman who I like a lot she started
asking secretary Halen about energy
poverty and basically should people
starve in the name of green energy
Terry do you
heard of the phrase energy G poverty
I have not heard of that term but I uh
probably pretty self-explanatory though
don't you think well I think what we're
really trying to do with our clean
energy goals is make energy more
affordable for a single Americans so I'd
like you to answer my question which is
do you believe energy poverty is a good
thing in other words the people going
into poverty or being unable to afford
food or medicine or things like that
because of the rising cost of energy do
you think that's a good thing
congresswoman I understand the
challenges that many Americans face I
raise my child as a single mom and had
to decide whether I could pay the rent
or my student loans so you a gas bill so
I understand that it's very difficult
yes so you agree that energy poverty is
not a good thing
she's a single mother so clearly she
knows Libby
I I honestly don't think they care I I
honestly don't think they care I think
in the Quest for their Green New Deal or
whatever it is they would gladly starve
half the world I really believe that
yeah and I think that's pretty clear
when you look at the numbers and when
you look at the gains
um economically that fossil fuel has
made throughout the world and when you
consider the expense that goes into you
know the electric cars and all of these
other kinds of energy systems they're
not affordable for a lot of people and
it reminds me of I think the play is
Uncle Vanya by checkup and I may have
mentioned this before but uh in the play
you have this guy and he's talking he
delivers this amazingly long monologue
about
um how terrible it is that the peasants
keep burning wood they keep burning down
the forest why are they doing that why
are they burning the forest down and the
reason of course that they're burning
the forest down is for heat so that they
can heat their homes so that they can
cook their food and there's another
option available which is to pick up
like Mulch off the forest floor and why
are they not using that well it's a much
dirtier energy it causes sickness it
causes filth all in the home so why are
they not using that
um that's why and so these these are old
questions why are the peasants using the
cheapest best energy source they can
find because it's the cheapest best
energy source that they can find and the
wealthy have always had the ability to
use whatever they think is going to be
better regardless of the cost but that's
just not true for the people of the
world it's certainly not true for the
poorest Americans who are not going to
be able to go out there and buy electric
cars just because gas powered cars are
no longer legal in so many states in
just a couple years speaking of the
poorest and the rich let's move on
because the left loves to pretend they
care about the poor while demonizing the
rich and then putting in policies that
just exacerbate that situation here is
congresswoman pramila jayapal and she's
just had it with those rich people and
she wants their money we have proven
with the child tax credit with survival
checks with so many provisions of the
American Rescue plan that poverty is a
bad policy Choice it is a choice and we
can make different choices that is the
good news my ultra millionaire Tax Act
which I'm proud to lead with my friend
Senator Elizabeth Warren would narrow
the racial wealth Gap help level the
playing field and ensure that the
wealthiest Among Us finally pay their
fair share just imagine what we could do
with the money that it would raise this
would be unprecedented investments in
health care in Universal child care in
education in transitioning to a
renewable energy economy in affordable
housing so that people could live and
wake up every day knowing that they were
able to provide for their families that
the Next Generation would do better than
our generation for way too long our
society has been rigged to favor the
wealthy this is a solution that would
give average people a fair Shake
you know I almost forgot for a second if
we leave my mic on during these video
clips and I almost said some really
horrible things about her so
I can't stand these people everything
she says there is a confusion or an
outright lie it's a government spending
problem the idea that the government if
they yes if you took all of Elon musk's
money into Peter thiel's money we'd
magically solve all these problems they
ruin absolutely everything you know rich
people they also hire a lot of people
and build a lot of stuff and innovate
and it's just nonsense but Sarah again a
certain set of people just buy this
drivel yeah and it's really sad too um
because it's people who are continually
told by people like this representative
jayapal that they are oppressed that
they can't make their own way that they
can't you know the the American dream
the reason why immigrants move here is
the idea that you know this is a
meritocracy that you can make your own
way that if you work hard you can you
can build your way up and you can become
something and you have an entire party
political party who is constantly
telling people you can't make your own
way the government has to do it for you
the government can create wealth as if
that's true and so I was listening to to
her talk and I I looked up because I
know that she's lying but I wanted to
look up the the most recent data that I
could find
um so in 2020 the IRS this is data from
the IRS shows that the top 25 percent of
earners paid nearly 89 of all income
taxes so should they keep talking about
paying their fair share like at what
what is what is fair they're already
paying 89 you want 90. you want 95 you
want the top 25 of earners to pay 100 of
all income taxes and nobody pay anything
else because guess what the three of us
know what's going to happen everyone
will be poor because that's what happens
it will only last for so long you can
only take Millionaires and billionaires
money before it just runs out this is
common sense but none of these people
again you know I I mentioned the
Secretary of interior and the climate
change issue everyone is disingenuous
this is no different because all these
legislators behind closed doors are
making money off of insider trading
they're coming out of Congress worth far
more than they were when they were
coming in Congress they're all the
Millionaires and the billionaires you
have Bernie Sanders who used to demonize
Millionaires and billionaires you'll
notice he doesn't say much about
millionaires anymore because he is one
of them none of these people somebody's
got to pay for those three houses
constantly
income because they just want they're
just buying votes that's all it is
unfortunately for the rest of us and for
all of America every time they do that
it affects all of us and it's not in a
good way
right let me just give you a little bit
more info here Libby before you jump in
this is from the daily wire uh Senator
Elizabeth Warren of Massachusetts
proposed a new tax bill alongside
Washington representative jayapal and
Pennsylvania representative Brendan
Boyle that would reportedly place a tax
on Ultra millionaire net worth and
households the tax would reportedly
place a two percent yearly tax on the
net worth of households and trusts above
50 million any households and trusts
that have a net worth over 1 billion
would have to pay another one percent
annual surtax this would lead
billionaires with a total tax of 3
percent Bloomberg wealth reports on the
individual billionaires that would
potentially be affected by such attacks
Jeff Bezos the world's richest person
would face an extra tax charge of at
least 5.4 billion in 2021 if the bill
became law while Elon Musk would pay 5.2
billion according to a Bloomberg
analysis the measure would cost Bill
Gates an additional 4 billion and Mark
Zuckerberg would have to pay a 2.9
billion over to cover the tax now just
again these things are just meaningless
because just because these guys are
super wealthy it doesn't mean they have
it all in liquidity as if they can just
hand over cash just like that they have
it tied up in a gajillion other things
but again even if you took all of that
freaking money Libby is there any reason
if you gave jayapal four billion dollars
and then you look at what she did with
it a year later is anything going to be
better is there any reason to think it
would be no I don't think it would
especially because of the way that the
Congress has been spending our money and
that Biden continues to you know insist
our money be spent paying off student
loan debt for gender studies degrees
that are absolutely meaningless and
these people have no skills and can't
get jobs we already saw that Harvard
students According to some professors
don't have the skills to read The
Scarlet Letter one of our most storied
novels that I was assigned in ninth
grade uh the only reason we weren't
assigned it in the eighth grade is
because of content you know if there's
adultery and whatever else
um but no I do not think that they would
do a very good job with this money I
don't think that they would take this
money and spend it anywhere within the
United States that was worthwhile they
would use it to continue destroying our
border they would use it to continue
funding this useless war in Ukraine they
would use it to enact laws that require
everyone to buy electric cars and to
further their racial social justice
initiatives in climate and companies and
all of these other things they would use
it to continue building this new medical
industrial complex that Biden is doing
after he enacted I think an EO about
building this extra medical situation so
that there can be even more trans
surgeries for kids across the United
States or whatever else that he wants to
do so no I don't trust these people with
my money I don't trust them with Jeff
Bezos money or Elon musk's money and I
certainly don't trust them with the
money that belongs to the taxpayers of
the United States Libby I don't I I
can't let you gloss over something you
just said there are you telling me that
you couldn't read The Scarlet Letter in
eighth grade because of adultery you had
to read it in ninth grade and now
basically half the country wants uh drag
queens to twerk in front of
four-year-olds is that what you're
telling me yes
all right I got I got one more on this
as long as we're talking about economics
because this headline just like this
actually enraged me it's hard to get
people think of me as even keeled Biden
to hike payments for good credit home
buyers to subsidize high-risk mortgages
listen to this home buyers with good
credit scores will soon encounter a
costly surprise a new federal rule
forcing them to pay higher mortgage
rates and fees to subsidize people with
riskier credit ratings who are also in
the market to buy houses the fee changes
will go into effect May 1st as part of
the federal Housing Finance agency's
push for affordable housing and they
will affect mortgages originating at
private Banks across the country you
know as somebody that at one time in my
life was in debt and someone at one time
I left it had to do credit card
consolidation and had bad credit and all
of those things and now has no debt and
profitable companies and good credit
score and pays my mortgage that pisses
me the fr why am I doing this work I
mean is that not completely bananas
Libby I'll start with you on this one I
have some really Choice words for that
plan as someone also who have has gone
through similar things plenty of things
if you want to write them down if you
want to write them down instead of
saying I find that help you know uh I
recently bought a home I worked
extremely hard to get to a place where I
could buy a home I bought it at one of
these ridiculous interest rates that we
have going now I got my credit up to a
reasonable position after years and
years of struggle to do that and it's
absolutely infuriating that this
Administration would think that just
because I work my ass off this whole
time that means I should subsidize other
people's poor choices I don't have any
interest in doing that and it's like
they completely forget that high risk
mortgages is what led to the 2008
housing collapse that destroyed
everything for years and saw college
graduates get out of school unable to
get any kind of job or have any kind of
hope for the future and say ridiculous
things about how now they can never have
children or whatnot even though
Millennials are apparently doing fine
now but when you look at this this is
not my responsibility to make sure that
other people other people's high risk
mortgages get sorted out I very
intentionally never engaged in a
high-risk mortgage even though of course
that's an option to lots of people to
make really poor financial choices once
you make those poor financial choices
that's on you Sarah is the punishment
the point meaning they could figure I
don't agree with any of this at all but
like if they didn't want to punish a
certain set they're responsible people
they could just figure out a way to
potentially help the high risk people
but it seems to me that the punishment
of the people who have played by the
rules is baked in here right meaning you
could just you could help people get
some sort of subsidized mortgage if
that's what your intention was without
harming the people who've done it right
but that's reverse of what they're
trying to do here yeah I do think
punishment at this point is the point I
also would just like to you said that we
could write it down so I just I wrote I
wrote I wrote mine down I still I still
censor just for you Dave but I did write
it down I'm mostly scribbling things
here that I can't even use words anymore
at this point
look I mean from each according to his
ability to each according to his need
right who said that Karl Marx because
with Communism you have to you have to
dumb everyone down to the lowest level
to maintain that equal playing field you
notice the administration always likes
to use the term Equity used to be
equality here in America now it's Equity
because we used to be a meritocracy
where everyone would have equal
opportunity now as you mentioned they
want to bring everyone down to the
lowest common denominator because you
can't have communism or socialism
without doing so so they have to make
sure that you are not motivated to to
innovate that you are not motivated to
make more money that you are you know
they can put their thumb on you all the
way until you are totally under their
control because as we all know uh the
the more chaos the more fear the more
poor the you know they infiltrate
Society with all of these things the
more able they are to control all of us
and that's essentially what it's all
about out I want to jump to one other
topic with you guys back to Florida here
we've got a tweet from ABC News uh
breaking the Florida Board of Education
votes to expand the so-called don't say
gay rules through 12th grade as you guys
know it's not called don't say gay it's
HB I think it's
hb1557 if I'm not mistaken uh originally
it was going to be up to third grade it
is not that they are never going to
allow you to say anything about gay
people the word gay is not even in the
thing it's that you will learn about
certain things related to gender and sex
inappropriate classes like Health not in
math or science Etc but Ted Liu Senator
congressman Ted Lou I cannot stand this
guy like he's to me at like Schiff he's
at like shift
um who else would I put in that swallow
territory here's what he said about it
kids in Maga States will be kept
ignorant they won't know gay marriage is
the law they won't be taught facts that
make them uncomfortable they will be
cuddled in a Maga bubble and when they
go to work or trade school or college
they will be made fun of and
disrespected
um he's a total I'm sorry he is just
such a dishonest scumbag I have gone
after well here's what I tweeted at him
just we'll just put it out there hey Ted
would you like to do my show so I can
call you a lying to your face uh
so you know sometimes I go with sugar
and sometimes I don't
Sarah again Gay's not in the thing
um just I'll I'll ask you a personal
question when you were growing up at any
point from kindergarten to 12th grade
did you know the sexuality of your
teacher their their sexual habits where
they sit were they pulling you aside and
calling you Sam instead of Sarah would
any of that have been remotely
appropriate or am I just am I just an
old angry guy at this point no I
actually did not know any of those
personal details about my teacher's sex
life and I think if I did the teachers
would have been pulled aside uh very
quickly and removed from their duties as
a teacher because anyone who was alive
up until about like two years ago knows
that that's not appropriate for children
the don't say gay thing pisses me off at
probably as well maybe as much as it
pisses you off I mean you're in Florida
I'm not in Florida but to see it
characterizes this so disingenuously you
might as well call it the don't say
straight bill I guess right because
clearly that's not what it is but you
know you look at how the left co-ops
this language in order to try to push
their agenda you see them do it with
black lives matter was that organization
at all about saving black lives I mean
there was one black life they saved in
particular who now lives in a giant
mansion that she bought with all of the
black lives matter money that they
raised yeah but other than that nothing
right you have antifa are they actually
anti-fascist I don't think so because
anytime I run into them they're
literally trying to shut my speech down
which is kind of fascist of them so they
just take these phrases and they
manipulate them to use whatever they
want to do to demonize us as if at the
end of the day any reasonable adult
wants children learning about sex in
class it just it's so disingenuous and
at the end of the day they have to do
this they have to talk about it's don't
say gay they have to frame it this way
because they know that any reasonable
American uh you see my cat up here hello
early
um any reasonable American who looks at
the actual content of the bill will say
yeah we don't want people we don't want
our children learning about sex it's
very simple that's why they have to
frame it like this because they know
they're not winning on the issues and by
the way Ted Lu 100 is lying and he knows
he's lying when he says they will not
learn about gay marriage it's not we
actually teach Civics in Florida they've
passed the bill so it will actually have
to be taught an honest assessment of
History will have to be taught so
they're not going to ignore Supreme
Court decisions it's about sexualizing
children with teachers and then you may
have seen it we should have shown it on
the show today uh cringe I call her
cringe Jean-Pierre yesterday saying that
gay teachers won't be allowed to have
pictures of their spouses on their desks
again it's a complete lie it was fact
checked on Twitter uh Libby it's never
gonna stop it's just never gonna stop no
I you know it's funny because the
parental rights and education bill as
it's more properly known was massively
popular among parents across the United
States there were polls done at the time
when I read the very short three-page
bill I was pleased with it I was hoping
that something similar would be enacted
in the state where I lived New York City
where instead there are policies that go
into effect that um encourage teachers
to keep students gender identity and all
of that kind of stuff secret from
parents right that's far more Twisted
that's far more twisted and that's true
in Vermont Washington State Colorado
California and a number of other places
and that is a horror so what you see
when you see the words don't say gay
Bill what you're actually seeing is a
Democratic party that is interested in
severing the ties between parents and
children and that is something that all
parents should be up in arms against
well speaking of that I got one more
thing for you a random guy Matt Wallace
I don't know who he is he tweeted this
out he said should permanent gender
surgeries for little kids be banned
immediately and he did it in all caps so
you know what people really mean it when
they say in all caps and uh this Elon
Musk guy who you might have heard of he
wrote absolutely uh Sarah this one's
been been sort of close to your heart
because you've been going to these
events which people can't believe they'd
be happening in Texas but they're
happening in Texas talking about the the
drag queen stuff which obviously is
connected then to the larger trans
movement
um Florida's outlawing it I think some
other states are going to Outlaw it very
soon Montana's outlawing it
um they're not going to transition kids
it again it's just it's so frustrating
because it's something that everyone
knew to be true up until 10 minutes ago
we all know we shouldn't be permanently
altering children's genitals like this
is it's not hard and it shouldn't be
controversial unfortunately the squeaky
wheel gets the grease in this country
and you have this minuscule number of
activists very radical activists Who
come out and and act as if we should be
doing it and the general population is
scared to say No actually that's abuse
and we won't stand for it the thing is
though as we see with Rhonda Santos as
we see with these other states that are
passing these bills this is a winning
issue it's not hard stop mutilating
children stop sexualizing children stop
bringing them to drag queen brunches so
adult grown men can twerk on them it's
not hard but we need everyone to
vocalize what we all know to be true
that is abusive and should not be
allowed Libby on the on the Elon part of
this how important do you think it is
not only that he got Twitter but that he
has suddenly become this cultural voice
that we desperately desperately needed
you know in terms of Twitter files but
also like basic sanity and also calling
NPR state-sponsored media and you know
CBC up and kind of like just like the
broad spectrum of things that he's doing
that putting aside Republican Democrat
the average person is just like yeah
that is refreshing and true and it's
nice that someone's saying it
yeah Elon Musk had said a lot of
controversial things and he's been
attacked by the left and right for them
which I think means he's pretty well
right over the target I appreciate that
he's been speaking out against medical
gender transition for minors uh mostly
the surgeries start around 13 and mostly
they affect young girls who have their
breasts permanently removed there have
even been doctors who perform these
kinds of surgeries who say things like
you know if they want their breasts back
they can just get breast implants later
as though there's anything similar
between having a bunch of plastic in
your body and having your actual body in
you know there in your body so that's
actually pretty stunning I appreciate
having Elon Musk speak out because he's
a very prominent figure and having
prominent figures speak out encourages
other people and lets them know that
they're not alone when they want to
speak out against things like puberty
blockers as well well I am encouraged by
you prominent speakers speaking out
Sarah Libby you guys are I love having
you both on today so we'll definitely do
this in the next couple weeks I thank
you have a great weekend and we got a
post game show coming up in about 42
seconds at
reubenreport.locals.com see everybody
the impact is not only potentially about
anything that might be in your medicine
cabinet and you know I'm not going to
get in your business but you should just
think about what might be in your
medicine cabinet
it could be all kinds of things that
that you need and a doctor prescribed
and that's your business with your dog
[Music]